happy Monday once again in quarantine
here in Los Angeles you're trying to
keep track of the length of how much
time we've been in quarantine
watch my pompadour collapse it is
crumbling as it grows it crumbles under
its own weight I've consulted a
structural engineer he said there's too
much on top and it's starting to come
over and that's what's happening right
now
the pompadour cannot sustain the
gravitational pull and so I'm getting
this kind of thing right now it will
eventually collapse completely crushing
my skull so look out for that that's
gonna be week nine you can you can track
this as we go anyway enough about me
let's talk more about me I had a nice
Mother's Day yesterday Mother's Day was
very nice what a wonderful day a chance
to spend quality time with loved ones
for the 78th day in a row sorry if I
seem bitter but really to celebrate now
it all goes in separate directions two
different bowling alleys but anyway I
don't want to Mar the sacred beauty of
Mother's Day I hope you all had a nice
one there's really no good transition
here but this is in the news a there's a
sex doll company that's now making a
realistic sex doll that actually makes
breathing noises yeah yet and actually
there's a a deluxe model that afterwards
says you're done already
[Laughter]